Hello everyone and welcome to lecture 8
of CME 296.
So today is a special day because as you
know today is the last lecture of this
entire class. So the menu for today will
be a little bit different. What we'll do
is we'll divide this lecture into two
parts. In the first part, we'll try to
push to piece together everything we've
seen in the class up until now and see
what we can take away from it. And in
the second part, what we look at is
adjacent fields where we can apply what
we have learned.
Does it sound good to you?
So with that what we'll do is we'll
start with the first part which is just
piecing together everything we've seen
this quarter
and
the whole goal of this class has been to
learn how to generate images. So for
instance given an input prompt how can
we generate an image that is
quite aligned with the prompt as input
and of course there is just a lot of
dimensions we can look at. So this class
has been about decomposing the fact of
learning how it works into tractable
parts. And if you remember the first
three lectures were about just
understanding how we could generate
images just let's suppose we have a
blackbox model what is the paradigm that
would allow us to just generate images.
So
the first lecture was about diffusion
just learning how we could do that using
the diffusion paradigm.
And if you remember the first thing
first thing we said was
what could be a good starting point for
us to generate those images. So if you
think about it, the images that we want
to generate, they're a part of a data
distribution that we do not know. And
that data distribution can be complex
and it's difficult to sample from it. So
one thing we said was okay, what are
some distributions that we know how to
sample from? So one such distribution
was the Gausian distribution.
And what we said was maybe in order for
us to sample from this complicated data
distribution, one thing we could do
could be to sample from an easy
distribution and then make our way up to
the complicated data distribution.
So in this first lecture what we said
was okay let's represent images with
just uh multi-dimension variables that
we could denote x and what we said was
okay in order for us to learn
how to go from gausian noise to clean
images what we'll do is we will come up
with a forward process that we define
that will allow us to corrupt clean
images into noise
and the purpose of diffusion is to learn
how to reverse that process.
So if you remember the forward process
was um a nice uh formulation that
involved also gausian distributions and
so in order for us to derive
the form of that reverse process.
What we did was we tried to maximize the
likelihood of um seeing that data
distribution under P theta and we went
through several steps that allowed us to
derive a loss. So if you remember uh
what we said was maximizing the
likelihood is actually not tractable. So
what we do is we derive a tractable
lower bound which was something where we
used the forward process that we defined
in it. So this lower bound is called
elbow and what we did is we expanded the
terms within within that lower bound and
we showed that we could actually compute
it. It was actually tractable.
And we ended up with a loss on us trying
to estimate the noise that was added to
a given image
through this very simple L2 regression
loss which had a noised image as input
along with its noise level. And it what
it was trying to do was to estimate the
amount of noise that was added to the
image or to the noisy image I should
say.
So this was a first way of looking at
things. So diffusion allowed us to go
from an easy to sample from distribution
so the gausian distribution to the data
distribution by learning
how to remove the noise.
The second lecture was about another way
of doing things which was
let's look at this data distribution not
from noise that you need to remove but
more in terms of where you need to go.
And we looked at a quantity called the
score which was defined as the gradient
of the log of P. And we saw that that
quantity had nice properties and in
particular it allowed us to not worry
about that normalizing constant that is
intractable.
And what the score was telling us was
where to go in order to to land at that
data distribution. And in particular,
there was a nice formula from Lvon
Dynamics which basically said that if
you knew how to compute the score, then
what you could do is sample from noise
and make your way to the data
distribution.
So the whole goal of this lecture was to
derive a way to estimate that score.
[snorts]
So the problem is the score is not the
quantity that that we know. So what we
did was
have a way to introduce the gausian
distribution
to some extent so that we can we can
leverage the properties that that we
know from the gausian distribution and
in particular the fact that we knew how
to compute in an analytical way the
score of a gausian distribution. So what
we did is we took observation from the
target data distributions and what we
did is we noised them
and then we looked at how we could
estimate the score of the noise
distribution.
So we saw that it was something that we
could actually compute.
But then there was a trade-off.
The more noise you would put in the data
distribution, the more your noise data
distribution would be far from the data
distribution of interest.
But then when you do that, you're able
to estimate that
score the score of the noise data
distribution quite easily. So you have a
trade-off of you can compute the
quantity but it's not the quantity that
you actually want
versus
if you have only a small amount of noise
then the score of that low noise data
distribution is actually not something
that you can estimate very well but
the target that you want to estimate is
closer to the actual quantity that you
want. So you had this trade-off and what
we said was well how about we estimate
the score
not just as a function of where we are
in space but also as a function of how
noised the data distribution is.
And we ended up with uh the den noising
score matching loss which allowed us to
estimate the score of that noise
distribution given a noise image and the
noise level.
And
once we did did that, we actually saw
that this way of looking at things was
actually very similar to the way we did
in the first lecture with diffusion.
And we saw that actually the score of
the forward process is equal to minus
the noise that you added over some
coefficient.
So both approaches led to similar
formulations and we saw that we actually
had this identity.
And then what we did was just realized
that the way we were noising our data
distribution was in a discrete way and
that there were many choices that you
had to take at the very beginning such
as how many steps you want to take and
so on. And so this motivated us
to move from a discrete formulation to a
continuous formulation.
So we derived the continuous formulation
of the for process which allowed us to
come up with this stochastic
differential equation which is the
delta in position during the forward
process which is equal to a drift term
that is deterministic
plus a diffusion term which is stoastic.
And here we're using the continuous
equivalent of the noise which as we saw
was the vener process DW.
And you could actually figure out how to
move your X when you wanted to noise it
with respect to these two terms.
And we actually saw that
the first approach that we looked at in
the first lecture and then the second
approach that we looked at here
were actually special cases of this more
generic formula.
In particular, the DDPM formulation from
lecture one was a variance preserving
formulation, whereas the one that we saw
with the noise condition score networks
was actually a variance exploding
formulation.
And then we what we did was okay, our
goal is not just to noise images, our
goal is to learn the reverse process.
And so in order to do that, the nice
thing was that in the 80s we have a nice
uh result that told us that for a given
forward process, you could have a
corresponding reverse process where you
actually needed to know the score which
is actually the quantity that we're
estimating here.
So what we had to do was just to
estimate the score in order to reverse
the process.
So long story short, lecture one we saw
okay in order to go from noise to clean
we need to predict the noise to remove.
In lecture two we said okay in order to
go from noise to clean we need to know
where we want to move towards which is
the score. You can think of the score as
a compass that tells you where the data
distribution is located.
And then we ended up in the third
lecture with a third way of looking at
things which is the flow matching
formulation
which actually frame the problem in a
different way. So what we did there was
to consider the noisy distribution in
the beginning as just an initial
distribution
and the data distribution of interest
was just a target distribution.
And the goal for us was to figure out
how to move your probability density
from an initial distribution to a target
distribution.
So that's the flow matching way of
looking at things. It's the point of
view of mass transport.
And in particular, there was one
quantity that was very important which
is called the vector field or the
velocity which is noted ut of x. It is a
vector that is defined at every position
and at all time t. And what we saw was
that in order to move each
observations from one point to another,
what we had to do was to just follow the
vector field. So we had this microscopic
way of looking at things which is the OD
that you see here. So d x over dt which
is equal to the vector field at the time
t and at the time and at position x.
And we also had a second way of looking
at this same thing. So the first
formulation is the microscopic
formulation which is what is happening
to your individual particles.
The second way of looking at this same
thing is at the macro level where what
you say is the evolution of the
probability at a given time t
is equal to minus the probability flux
which is what constitutes the continuity
equation
which just tells you that you're not
losing anything between time t equals 0
and one.
And the whole point of us going into
these formulas
was for us to figure out
a vector field
which would allow us to go from
this initial distribution to this target
data distribution.
So this was the whole point
and in particular let's assume
you know the vector field that you want
to estimate.
The strategy here would be to have a
model that estimates the vector field.
So here ut theta of x.
So let's assume you learn such a model.
If you do learn such a model, then in
order to sample from
the complicated data distribution which
is P1,
what you need to do is to just sample
from your easy data distribution P 0 and
then numerically solve the OD here
between time 0
and 1 using the vector field that you
have learned.
And we saw that it's actually something
that you can do in practice if you
construct the target vector field in a
way that makes it tractable. So we saw
conditional probability path which were
[snorts] an easier way of looking at
this which is okay we don't know what
the vector field in the general case how
about if we look at a simpler case where
we want to move the initial data
distribution not to the target data
distribution but to a single point
which was the conditional probability
path that we saw. And we saw that
we could obtain a conditional flow
matching loss that was equivalent to you
learning the vector field that was the
aggregate of all these conditional
vector fields that allowed you to solve
the problem of interest.
So these first three lectures were by
far the most mathematically challenging.
I hope what I said made sense. We spent
uh six hours on this and uh I hope I did
a good job in 10 minutes to just recap
what we did. At the end of it, I just
want you to remember that so we're in
2026.
People nowadays they use flow matching
by default. And so if you just want to
have something that you want to really
uh master um you know perfectly I would
recommend just really understanding the
flow matching part because this is what
most models nowadays use. In particular,
they use a variant that we saw that's
called the rectivi flow variant,
which was an extension of uh this that
allowed the path to be straighter so
that at inference time you could afford
having fewer steps in your in the
numerical uh solver here. So that you
can just sample images with fewer steps.
Okay. So, first three lectures most
matically mathematically challenging. It
was purely for us to learn a paradigm to
generate images.
But up until that point,
we assumed two things. So the first one
is we assumed that we were generating
images in an unconditioned way. So we
didn't have any input prompt. We did not
worry about this.
And the second thing was we just assumed
that we had a way to represent images.
So we just represented them with X with
I don't know n dimensional vector
but we did not see what representation
would make sense.
And this was the focus of lecture four
which was titled latent space and
guidance.
And what we saw there was well in order
to have a meaningful representation of
your images what you want is to have a
way to keep only the useful stuff. So
how do you do that? Well, in pixel
space, you see that you have a pretty
large amount of spatial correlation,
which means that if you look at a pixel,
a lot of the surrounding pixels are more
or less of that value. So, you can
imagine that there is a lot of redundant
information in there. So, that's number
one.
And number two is in the pixel space,
well, the dimensionality
is pretty high.
So given that the model that you're
going to build from it is going to be a
function of the dimension of your input,
what you want to do is to make sure your
input
is not too big. So you want to compress
the input into something that is only
keeping you the useful bits.
And in order for for us to do that,
we looked at a model that was called an
autoenccoder
whose only goal was
to learn a way to represent images into
a smaller space. That's called the
latent space.
So here on the slide you see that you
have the image in the pixel space as
inputs and then you have an encoder that
does some downsampling operations that
gets you some representation of the
input image not in the pixel space but
in a lower dimensional space which is
the latent space.
And what you do here is to use that
lower dimensional representation
in order to reconstruct
your input.
So you have a proxy task which is you
know how can you reconstruct the input
as best as you can by going through this
bottleneck.
And when you do that, you are indeed
able to learn a latent space that
compresses the information into just
fewer dimensions.
But then the problem that we encountered
was that if you did that, you had no way
of controlling the shape of the latent
space. And in particular, if you want to
learn how to generate images, what you
want is to have an easy time at learning
it. So you don't want a space with
spikes here and there and then nothing
in between.
So what you want is something more on
the at the top of the slide which is
a data distribution that is more compact
and well put together.
So in order for us to do that what we
did was go back to the way we formulated
things and add a constraint for us to
regularize
the latent space. And this was the VAE
that we saw, the variational
autoenccoder,
which allowed us to structure the latent
space in a way that would make our lives
easier.
And we saw that in order to derive a
loss for us to learn that model, we use
the same trick as lecture one, which
leveraged the elbow. So the evidence
lower bounds. Not going to go into
details but one thing I wanted to say
here is we ended up with a loss that had
two terms.
One was the pixelwise reconstruction
loss which we had previously
but also a second term that was aiming
at structuring the latent space as much
as possible to a certain distribution
that was called the prior distribution P
of Z.
so that we can have something that looks
a little bit more like the top one.
Cool. So that was really the focus of
that uh session and we also learned how
to represent the inputs. So we saw
different encoders in a particular
transformerbased
encoders including the VIT vision
transformer and then we saw that there
are ways to combine different modalities
in the same space. for instance with
clip using a contrastive loss.
And then we also saw methods to
incentivize our generation to be more
aligned with our condition. And here if
you remember we looked at classifier
free guidance that allowed us to do
that.
Cool. So up until that point, we knew
how to generate images in terms of the
way we wanted to go about doing this. We
knew how to represent the input and we
knew how to represent our noisy latent.
Well, now the question is okay, what
model are you actually going to use to
to do that? And this was lecture five
which was on image generation
architectures.
And here we took a step back and just
reminded ourselves of the problem that
we have at hand which is we have a model
and what we want to do is to predict a
quantity that will allow us to go from
noise to clean.
So as I mentioned the paradigm that is
by far the most common these days is the
flow matching paradigm. So it's in
particular a model that would predict
the velocity.
So what we want is a generation model
that takes in a noise level,
the condition of interest like your user
prompt and then your noisy latent as
input in order to predict the velocity.
And we saw that one popular architecture
was the unit
which was composed of two main parts.
The first one was a downsampling part
which allowed to gain a global
understanding of the input through
downsampling operations
which allowed its receptive field to be
bigger and bigger. So here what we mean
is when you compute the activation map
if you take a single value what we're
saying is that that value was a result
of a pretty wide input.
So that's the downsampling part and then
the upsampling part was just a way for
us to match the shape that we wanted.
And we had these copy and crop
connections
that allowed us to transfer lower level
details that were computed as part of
the downsampling operation.
So this was the unit. But of course you
know that in 2017 transformers
just took the whole field by storm and
there was more and more models that were
relying on the transformer and the self
attention mechanism and it was not long
after that the diffusion transformer
came into play. So in 2022 I believe um
so that architecture dealt with a
limitation of the unit which was that
patches that were far from one another
from the image could not have a direct
way of interacting with one another.
And in cases like you know if you wanted
to generate an image of let's say a
teddy bear that looks at himself in the
mirror then you would want to have that
interaction to figure out the lower
level details.
And we saw that that diffusion
transformer was injecting conditions
using an adaptive layer norm framework.
So it was just modulating the embeddings
of the patches
and then we saw that you know today is
uh May 29th 2026. So now we have a lot
of such models out there and in
particular there is one specific
category that has emerged which is the
multimodel
diffusion transformer which on top of
doing the self attention mechanism also
considers the condition as part of the
joint attention
and we looked at the timeline. So here
what's in blue is units and what's in
green is DT and variance. And of course
the timeline is not exhaustive but it is
just a way for you to see that nowadays
image generation models are
almost everyone is relying on the DIT
based architecture.
Cool. And then um at that stage we knew
how we could generate images. We knew
how to represent the input. We knew how
to represent the latence. We knew what
model to use. But we didn't know how to
train that model. And that was the focus
of lecture six.
And so before digging into the details,
one thing we wanted to just align was
how we wanted our time step to be
sampled during the training cuz we had
seen back in lecture one to three that
the time step that we were sampling in
order to train our model was drawn from
a uniform distribution.
And we spent some time just thinking
about whether all noise levels are
equally hard or not.
And we saw that noise levels that are
not super noisy but not towards clean
like those in the middle were the most
difficult because those were the places
where we had to make important decisions
about where to go. And so that's the
reason why the fact of sampling from a
uniform distribution
was not the most optimal. And we saw
that there was this uh distribution
called the logit normal distribution
which is a distribution that focuses
much more on the middle steps was
something that was more commonly used
these days. And we saw that not only
that, but
the resolution of your images also
matter in terms of what the perceived
noise is. And in particular, if you want
to train a model on higher resolution
images, what you want is to make sure to
noise your images a bit more than what
you did previously. Because for a given
noise level, a lower resolution image
will appear as being more noisy compared
to a higher resolution one. And we did
some math on the blackboard if you
remember when we computed just the
uncertainty around the underlying pixel
value. But intuitively it comes from the
fact that there is spatial correlation
within your image. So if you have more
pixels to represent let's say an area of
the image well if you noise
some of it and if you have more chances
to see the actual value then when you
look at the image you will have an
easier time to see what the image is
about as opposed to if you have a lower
resolution image.
So if you have pixels that are noised
then you have fewer chances of seeing
the underlying true pixel value pixel
value.
And so with that we saw that there are a
few stages to a typical model training
process. The first one being
pre-training which is learning how to
generate images. And so here you have so
it's the most time consuming and
expensive part of the whole pipeline
because you need to come up with a very
big corpus of images that encompasses
all of the possible
images that you want to generate and it
needs to be certain quality and you need
to have good mixtures and so on. So a
lot of effort is put into having
a pre-trained data that is reflective of
the way you want your image generation
to to learn. And
after that we saw that once you get an
image generation model that learn that
that knows how to generate images, what
you wanted to do is to generate good
images and in particular good here
can be something that people say just in
the aesthetics term. So you want your
image to look good, but you also want
your image generation model to know how
to generate images in your field of
interest or in your task of interest.
So for instance, if you have an image
generation model that has been
pre-trained on let's say nature and then
I don't know houses, but if you want
that model to generate images of let's
say teddy bears. So what you want is for
instance to have an extension of that
training that's that we call continued
training where you teach your model how
to generate images in your
set of images of interest which here can
be teddy bears.
And what we saw was that a third
optional step could be the tuning step
where you could have a situation where
you want to generate images of one
particular subject of one particular
person many times.
So if you are in that situation, what
you want is to tweak your model in a way
that will remember what you wanted to
generate.
And we saw dream booth as a way for us
to do that. So the idea was to gather a
set of images, so five to 10 typically
that contains
who you want to depict.
And what you do is you train your model
to generate images that contain that
specific person or that specific object
while having a rare token as input. So
what you were teaching your model was to
rewire its brain towards generating
something when it saw a specific token.
And given that these models can be
pretty big, we saw that there were also
techniques to tune not all weights but a
subset of the weights through this
technique called Lura, low rank
adaptation.
And
once you did that, okay, let's suppose
you did either the first two or all
three of the steps, what you want is to
now deploy your model to production. So
what you want is to have a model that
does not cost you a lot and also does
not take a lot of time to make
generations. So we saw a bunch of
methods that were aimed at shortening
the number of steps that were needed for
you to generate samples. So this
category of methods is called
distillation.
So we saw a number of methods. Um so I
would encourage you to uh look at uh
that lecture. So there was progressive
distillation as one example but uh some
others as well.
And then
finally last week what we said was okay
great we can do all this but we have not
seen how we could evaluate how our
images h how how good they were. And if
you don't know how to do that well you
don't know where to put your efforts. So
you need to know how well you're doing.
which is why lecture 7 was focused on
evaluating images and in particular how
good those images were. [snorts]
So we saw that the most common way
people evaluate images on things like
leaderboards
is by having images generated by the
models that are in your leaderboards and
by having pair-wise comp comparisons
between them. And we saw that there was
a particular way of measuring
performance that took into consideration
the history of each model. And by
history I mean how people rated
that model.
And the reason for that is we saw that
if you were to win against a weak model,
it is not the same thing as if you were
to win against
a strong model.
So you want to take into consideration
how strong your opponent is. Otherwise,
a metric like the win rate would be very
dependent on who you are making your
comparisons with.
And we saw this metric called the ELO
rating, ELO score that looked at this in
the following way. So if you were to
rate different models, so you have a
ratings, let's call it R,
that quantifies how good each model is.
So in order for you
to
let's suppose you have a new model you
want to compute its rating. So what you
would do is compare that new model to
let's say a model that is part of the
list and you would use the rating of the
models
to quantify how good they are and take
that into consideration in order to find
the rating of the new model.
So how do you do that? Well, the idea is
quite simple. So the ratings quantify
how good models are. So from that
quantity what you can do is to compute
an expected what you expect will happen.
So for instance if you have a strong
model and a weak model well what you
expect is the strong model to win.
So you compute a quantity which is the
expected score which is a function of
these two ratings
and you compare that with the actual
score
and the difference between that which is
here delta
tells you how surprised you are. So if
you won against a strong model then you
want your delta to be high and if you
won against a a weak model then it's not
like a lot of signal for you because you
know almost everyone wins against that
weak model so delta would be lower.
So all of that to say that you will come
across the ELO score quite a lot. And I
just want you to remember that the ELO
score is a smart way of computing
pair-wise comparisons by taking into
consideration how strong your opponent
is if you compare model A and model B.
Cool. But not everyone has the luxury of
having human ratings for everything they
do. So that's why we also have a bunch
of automated metrics. So we looked at
one that was quite popular
uh nowadays which is called the FID
score fresh inception distance. So what
this score does is it computes the
distance between the distribution of
your generated images and the
distribution of real images.
And the idea is if these distributions
are far
then it means that your generated images
they don't look
like real images.
And we saw that the FID score so I
didn't put the formula here but it is
something that is derived from a more
general formulation
and here the actual formula is derived
considering that these two distributions
are considered as gausian.
So that's the assumption that we're
doing when we're computing this metric.
And we saw that the lower this metric
was, the better it was. And of course,
it's a proxy, so it's not a perfect
metric.
And then we looked at more clever ways
of obtaining scores in particular by
leveraging
these newer models. So here MLM which
stands for multimodel large language
models that
are able to both take text but also
images as inputs. So you could very well
say okay you have this image, you have
this input prompt. Well tell me how how
it looks like or how how good that is.
Then you could obtain some given scores.
And we saw that you also had a way to
leverage these models
in order for you to not have to ask your
humans to rate your images, but to ask
your MLM as a judge to rate them for
you. You could have a tighter loop that
would allow you to make iterations
faster
and have human ratings when you feel
like your model is good enough for you
to to take that step.
And this [snorts] was CME 296. So you
see that in order for us to generate an
image from a prompt there is a lot that
goes underneath.
And this is what the whole lectures 1 to
7 were about.
Cool. So now you finished this class
after this lecture and you're like okay
now I know all of this and so what? So I
wanted to talk to you about the
state-of-the-art models that were out
there. So what we did was just go to a
popular arena that
ranks the best models out there. So
there's a leaderboard and as you can see
there is the ELO score that is used to
determine those ranks. I just wanted to
look for us to look at which models were
the best and whether they were also
using the methods that we saw in this in
this class or not.
So let's start with the best models out
there. And we see that we have the first
two ranks that are from OpenAI. So GPT
image and then we have two models from
Google. And then the fourth uh sorry the
fifth model is from uh XAI. So it's all
closed source models from top AI labs.
The problem with those models is we
don't know how they work because they
they're not publishing any reports. So
there's not a lot I can tell you, but
that leaderboard also ranks open weight
models that have technical reports that
are
published that are public and available.
And here, so it's a screenshot that
dates from like 5 days ago. And we see
that the highest ranked model is from um
from a company called Hydra. So it's
Hydream 01 image number one and then you
have Quinn image that we saw in lecture
five when we talked about the multimodel
diffusion transformer
and then the ranks three to five are
from this model from Black Forest Lab
called Flux 2.
And what I wanted us to do was to go
through these models and see what they
were made of.
So let's start with the the last ones,
the flux two models. So
they're based on rectified flow which as
I mentioned is a derivative of flow
matching. So something that we know
their architecture is based on the
diffusion transformer but in particular
what that architecture is is based on is
a combination of single stream and
double stream diffusion transformer. So
this is also something that we saw.
[snorts]
So they rely on a VAE to make sure that
the latent space is compact and allows
you to learn easily. So that's also
something that we saw. And we also
happen to have some text encoder that
was pre-trained and here it's a Mistro 3
that is used
to generate the embeddings.
So up until now the usual, right?
Okay, let's go to the model number two.
So, Quinn image, the loss is a flow
matching loss. So, also something that
we know.
So, the architecture is a multimodel
diffusion transformer
and it also relies on a VAE and the text
embeddings are based on Quen
also the usual. Now let's look at the
top ranked model which by the way was
published I think two weeks ago so it's
extremely recent
so
flow matching loss also similar to what
we saw the model is not exactly a
multimodel diffusion transformer but
it's something that is based on the
transformer so also very similar
But
turns out that there is no more VA
and
there is no pre-trained text encoder.
So does that mean that what we learned
was not true? Like what's going on? So
let's see how that relates to what we
learned.
So that paper what it does is it
actually performs
the generation not in a latent space but
in pixel space.
And now you may think well how how is
the dimensionality going because it's
much higher than a latent space. So
that's the first question. And then the
second question is pixel space is much
harder for you to learn because we saw
that in the space
valid images in the pixel space are more
isolated. They're not smooth
distribution.
Well here here is my interpretation.
So first of all for the dimensionality.
So it turns out that the patch size that
the paper uses is not the traditional
2x2 that we're used to for latent space.
It's actually a much bigger one. So it's
a 32x 32.
So computationally here the idea is to
make it tractable by just having bigger
patches.
And then when it comes to learnability,
well,
the fact of not having an easy space to
learn from is just shifting the effort
that needs to happen over to the
diffusionbased transformer.
And so what I found very interesting
with this paper was
even if you make your problem harder for
your diffusion transformer or your
transformerbased model,
well you can still have amazing results
if you scale it well enough because that
model well turns out that it was scaled
I believe to 8 billion and then also to
200 billion parameters which is huge for
image generation models.
And so what I wanted to say was that the
space is fast moving, that what we
talked about still holds true, but
that the trade-off between making it
easier for the transformer to learn
versus doing it in the raw space is
still something that was being figured
out because there's something that I
have not mentioned which is when you
learn the latent space. So you're making
it easier for your model to learn.
You're having a more compact space,
but then the main thing that you're
losing
is fidelity
because it's a lossy operation for you
to operate in a space that is not your
original space.
So you know when you train your VA you
you just hope that you will reconstruct
things truthfully but it is not always
the case and it just turns out that this
paper
shows that
the VA the downside of the VA are such
that we could maybe work without it if
you scale things
in a in a big enough
So I found that interesting and I think
it's a newer trend of doing things
without VA. So I think it's just good
for us to keep an eye on this. So again
this paper was published a few weeks
ago. I don't want to make general
statements because maybe in a couple of
months then we will see maybe that the
VA is necessary but I think this is a a
part that is worth watching.
Cool. So any questions on that?
Yeah.
Oh yeah. So the question is what is the
alternative to pre-trained encoder? So
the alternative is to just learn it
yourself.
So instead of having a pre-trained
encoder computing the embeddings for
you, what you do is you take the text as
input. What you do is you just tokenize
it. So you divide it into arbitrary
units of text and you learn their
representation as part of your training.
And so there is one thing I didn't uh
say here, but um
they're not using a pre-trained text
encoder to do that, but they're doing
some kind of prompt enhancement
that allows you to be more explicit
about the input prompt. Because you may
have a prompt like a teddy bear is
reading, but in order to generate a very
good image, you need to know for
instance how the lighting should be,
like what what um the camera position
should be and so on. And so that piece
is also making the job of the text
encoder easier because it just explicit
the
what you need to have as condition.
Yeah.
So the question is if there is no
disjointed text encoder, how are they
able to understand text? So here the the
keyword is pre-trained. So there's still
a text encoder, but it's just not
something that you take off the shelf.
It is something that you train yourself
as part of the training.
Okay, cool. So this concludes part one
which was around recapping what we did
up until now.
So
now that we know all of this what I want
us to do is to see how adjacent field
can benefit from what we have learned.
And a very natural extension that I want
to talk to you about is
videos.
So if you think about it, videos are
nothing else than a sequence of frames
which are images. So you just have an
extra dimension. So here you go from a
2D image to a 3D image
across time.
And the question now for us is what
should we have in mind when we want to
build a video generation model
and what are the things we can use from
what we have learned in order for us to
be able to do that. So the first thing
that I want to tell you is there is an
extra dimension which is time.
The second thing that I want to talk to
you about is that in a video you need to
make sure that there is some temporal
consistency as in you cannot go from one
frame to the other
in in a way that completely change what
you're looking at.
But you also need to make sure that
whoever is being depicted in your frames
do not have suddenly things that they
did not have. So for instance, if you're
looking at a video of teddy bear
reading, you don't want the teddy bear
to all of a sudden acquire a hat and
sunglasses at t plus one, but then at t
not have any of those.
So this is an extra thing that you need
to worry about. So for images you wanted
to generate something that was
plausible.
For videos you need to generate
something that looks plausible at a
given time t. But you also need to make
sure that
the way frames are are sequenced is also
making sense. So you need to have that
temporal consistency.
And of course you need to make
computation structable because here as
you can imagine if we go the route of
representing our input as a sequence of
2D images. Well the dimension just got
increased by a factor of t which is the
time. And so you need to make sure that
whatever you're doing is making things
still tractable.
And of course metrics as well and well
I'll just u get you the spoiler. So we
still leverage the metrics that we have
seen for images but we just extend them
for videos. So the fresh inception
distance FID is something that you may
also see in the video world where the
only thing that changes is the
representation
of the quantities that you're dealing
with. So instead of having the inception
network to represent your image, what
you're doing is you're using a
pre-trained encoder that would represent
your videos.
And you have for instance this metric
called the fresh video distance that
tells you how far apart your videos
generated videos are from real ones
using a similar method. But I want to
call out one thing. These metrics are
just proxies.
So it's always good to have human in the
loop.
Okay. So now
let's see how we can handle
just generating videos by going through
specific parts of the architecture that
we may need to change.
So if you think about it, an image
generation model, a traditional image
generation model is
a DIT based model operating in a latent
space.
So you have a VAE that compresses your
input into some latent space
and then you obtain
let's say the final prediction that you
then decode back in your initial space.
Well, the same thing is happening for
videos.
So here you not only are compressing
from a spatial perspective, you're also
performing a temporal compression.
So do you remember when we talked about
f which was the ratio of the height in
your initial space over the height in
your latent space?
Do you remember? So maybe I'll just
quickly So we had this
pixel space and then we have the latent
space here and then you have h
and then h here.
So we had f the spatial uh compression
which was just a ratio of big h over
little h and that ratio is typically on
the order of eight for spatial
compression.
Here what you also want to do is to
compress your input along the time
dimension as well.
So why do you want to do that? Well, the
first thing is you want to make sure
your problem is tractable from a
dimension dimensionality perspective.
But then the second reason is when you
compress things in a smaller space, what
you're assuming is you have redundant
information.
So spatially we saw that we have spatial
correlation meaning around some pixels
you have pixels of the similar value so
you have redundant information. Well
it's the same along the time axis as
well
because you can you can very well
imagine that if you go through the
frames of a video two consecutive frames
will have a lot of the same information.
So it would also make sense for you to
compress things also along the time
axis.
And so here this compression ratio which
we saw was for space is also something
that we have along the time dimension.
And as a result your latent space is
composed not not of space latence but of
space-time latence.
So what that means is the quantities
represent not only things that
are within a given image but also with
respect to time.
So there is one thing that you may find
interesting which is that the dimension
over t is 1 + t and then the latent
space is of dimension 1 / t over 4.
But then you may ask okay why why the 1
plus why one? And I would say it's a
good question. It's also a question I
asked myself. Well, it turns out that if
you want to generate a video,
you need to have a starting point. You
need to have an initial frame.
Well, that one
is a way for us to consider the first
frame as being something special. It has
a special place. It's an it's the anchor
frame. We want to make sure we're
representing we're representing it as
well as possible.
And so the reason why we have the
oneplus is to represent that first
frame, that anchor frame to its fullest
extent. And then to use that as a way to
continue the video in a way that
is a natural continuation of that first
frame.
Does that make sense?
So, by the way, we're going super
quickly over a lot of things. So, my
goal is to just give you some pointers
for if you're just interested, let's say
after today, and you want to just
explore more. These are just some like
small little things. The second thing I
wanted to talk about with respect to the
VAE is so as we said it is not a 2D VA
it's a 3D VA because it's operating also
along the time dimension.
So you will see that that VAE is called
a causal
VAE.
So why causal? So causal is because
when you perform let's say convolutions
which is typically what one of the
operations that VA contains
you perform your convolution in a in a
symmetric manner.
But here what you want to do
for a given frame is to not compute
feature [snorts] maps that are a
function of future frames. you only want
for that frame to be a function of the
same frame and the frames before.
So that is why it's called a causal VA.
It's because
the convolution is not like the
symmetric one that you're thinking of.
It's asymmetric.
And the reason why people would do that
do does do that is actually for several
reasons but one of the reasons is you
don't want to go out of memory every
time you do these things. So what people
do is sometimes they stream this
encoding process and if you make sure
that a given frame is not dependent on
the future frames which by the way the
receptive field can widen if you have
several convolution operations. So if
you make sure that it only depends on
that frame and the frames before
then computationally speaking you can
actually stream that encoding and
decoding process.
Just giving you
reason why. And then the second thing
that I wanted to talk about with respect
to the video oh yeah you have a
question.
So yeah great question. So the question
is why would you need frames before the
last frame? So let me give you an
example. So let's suppose
a teddy bear walks across the street
and the camera looks at that teddy bear
and it sees a pedestrian that is coming
this way
and then later on that pedestrian comes
back.
So the information of who is going
behind that teddy bear is something that
is important to you. You want to be able
to capture things that makes your video
consistent. So that temporal
consistency, which is making sure you're
not inventing
objects or people in your video that may
have happened in the past.
So that's the reason why you want your
receptive field
to not be one.
So you want to have some dependency on
earlier frames compared to the the last
one.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah, the question is uh yeah efficiency
concerns and yeah I hear you. So um
there is something we'll discuss which
is exactly what is happening in the
latent space. So of course you cannot
generate a video of you know very very
big time t. So what people do is divide
the generation into several parts where
you can generate a video of let's say a
fixed length and then take the last
frame as the anchor frame to generate
another video of let's say another fixed
length. So one way for you to make this
more tractable is to just take the last
frame of the video that you generated as
the first frame and then continue later
on along with some condition.
So yeah.
So the the question here is how can you
um teach your model how to generate the
next frame given the given some
conditions. So we're actually going to
see that in the next slide. So this part
is just about compressing the input, but
we're not yet generating the video. So
we're going to see that in just one
second, but yeah, great question.
Cool. Any other questions? Okay, so I'll
answer your question right now.
The way we generate videos is within
that latent space similar to how we do
it for image generation. We have this
DIT based architecture that works from
patches and that generates patches.
The main difference from images is that
these patches
they are not space patches. They're not
spatial patches. They're spacetime
patches. And what that means is as
input, we have if you want something
that represents
some part of the of the
let's say image, it's not really image
because you're in the latent space
across time.
And
in order for you to think that you're
doing a good job as producing a video
that is consistent with oneself, one
thing that you can tell yourself when
you're looking at that whole process is
that within the DIT, you have the self
attention mechanism that allows your
space-time patches to interact with one
another so that you're producing an
output that is coherent.
across space but also across time.
So I think your question also involves
some amount of how can you make sure
that it reflects
causality. So can you expand on what you
mean by causality?
Yeah. So the question is okay how can
you make sure you have some causality
versus correlation? I think at the end
of the day what you're doing is you're
training your model on some data and the
resulting model is just reflecting the
patterns that it has seen at training
time. So if you feed it things that
reflect uh for instance if you put uh I
don't know a book on a table and there's
some dust that uh goes away these are
the patterns that your model will also
learn. So I think at the end of the day
it all goes back to what kind of data
you put inside.
So yeah that's how I would think about
it. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So the question is uh well we know
in LLM we have a masked self attention
that makes things causal. Maybe there's
something that we can reuse here. Um
well in the image generation world we're
making sure that all parts of the image
they interact with one another and this
is actually something that we also have
here. The main reason being that you
want some consistency between every part
of your video. And so for that reason
people typically keep the full self
attention.
Um, but then at the end of the day, you
you need to try it out and see how it
works. But yeah, typically people keep
the self attention. Yeah.
Okay, great. So that model that we just
saw is a model that is open weights.
It's called one. There are actually
multiple models out there and this list
of readings is by no means
comprehensive.
So in case you're interested, feel free
to just take a look at those. Um so I
know one is one such model. I I believe
there's also LTX as well. Um yeah,
highly recommend uh reading the papers.
I would say that given the fact that you
know how image generation models work,
it's now much much easier to understand
these papers. So yeah, hopefully that's
going to be helpful.
Cool. So video generation was one
adjacent field that I wanted us to touch
on. The second topic that I wanted us to
talk about is image editing.
So let's imagine that you have an image
and what you want to do is to edit that
image. So you can say okay make this
image black and white.
So you could very well use what we have
learned which is you put that into your
text image to image model. So TI2I. So
how do you do that? Well, you represent
your condition which is the text and the
image as part of let's say your MMDIT
and you inject that and you can obtain
an output image. Well, the problem here
is that you're considering this problem
as a from scratch generation problem.
So you're telling your model, make this
image black and white. And what you're
expecting is that exact same image but
black and white. And you can just ask
yourself, okay, is it actually
opti optimize the what I'm doing? So
what I'm doing is I'm asking a model to
generate a whole thing from scratch
and I have no guarantee that it's the
same image.
So the question here is is there a
better way for image editing tasks
to edit your image spec specifically in
cases where you want the input image to
be preserved. Is there a better way to
edit those images than to consider this
as a from scratch generation problem?
Well, so in this case, you see that the
black and white image had the teddy bear
raised its right arm and this is not
what you want. So people have been
thinking about this problem from another
angle.
So what they're saying is instead of
considering this as an image generation
problem,
let's actually
think about this problem as an image
editing problem. And by editing I mean
in the sense of performing some
operations on the image.
So one idea could be to have your image
to have your prompt be fed into a VLM.
So vision language model which is an MLM
multimodel large language model
in order for you to receive editing
actions
that could be maybe okay um decrease the
let's say brightness by I don't know 50%
just increase the luminosity by x%.
that you could then
interact with an editing software like
Photoshop
in order to get your final image.
So the nice thing with this approach is
well first of all you have some
guarantee that you are preserving your
initial image. If let's say you're
constraining the sets of actions that
you're taking to let's say an allow list
of actions that here can only be
harmless like coloring actions.
But one challenge is for your VLM to
know
your the set of possible actions well
enough
for the editing action to actually make
sense.
So that's the main challenge
and so that's why some people I mean
when I say some people like a lot of
people are trying to think about how to
do this. So there's a very short list of
papers that um try to resolve that. But
there is one
method that I want to mention here which
is how do we want
our output like how can we make sure
that our output is something that is
aligned with something that makes sense.
Well, a possible method is to look at
the logs
of people who are actually making edits.
So, let's assume you go to your favorite
editing software, you have an input
image, and then you make some edits and
then you have a final image.
Well, the sequence of edits that you
made is something that your model can
learn from.
Well, the only thing that your model
doesn't really know
is what your intent was because you
typically don't tell your editing
software, well, I want to um make my
image more like this. You don't say
that.
So these papers so most of them what
they're trying to do is
to
come up with pairs of initial image
edited image along with a user intent
that is inferred by these two images
let's say from annotators
and what they're doing is they're tuning
the VLM
on these golden sets
in order to have it be more have it
behave more like something that would
tell you actions that would correspond
to your intent.
So that's why you have papers on this is
just because that in order for your
model to learn how to do these things,
you need to do some work in terms of
which data to use, how you want to train
these things.
And that's why they're here. So yeah,
highly recommend reading them. It's an
open area of research. If you take a
look at the years they were published, I
mean they were published 2024, 2025,
2026. So extremely hot.
Any questions? Yeah.
So the question is how can the loss
reflect the user intent? Well, the thing
is you are not using the loss to infer
the user intent. So, one possible way of
inferring user intent is to feed an
offthe-shelf VLM an initial image and an
output image and to tell your VLM, well,
tell me what changed between these two
images in order to infer this box, you
know, make this image black and white.
So, I'll give you an example.
If we feed a VLM the colored image and
the black and white image and we ask the
VLM well come up with something that
tells me what changed between this and
that image. It gives you the user intent
and then what you can do is use that
user intent
along with the initial image
and then you can of course collect the
editing action that the user took and
tune your VLM to output these editing
actions given this input.
So yeah, that's one popular way I've
been saying this papers.
Yeah,
cool.
Great. So, now we're in the last part of
what I wanted to talk to you about and
that part is actually an area that I
think is a very very hot area uh which
is how can we apply diffusion to the
field of LLMs.
So as you know there's been a lot of
transfer of knowledge from what has
worked well in the text world to the
vision world.
So in the text worlds as you know in
2017 we had the transformer that was
initially designed for translation
tasks. So let's suppose you want to
translate from English to French. What
you do is you use this transformer to
have some let's say English text as
input in order to have a generated
French text as output.
And as you know well people in the
vision world they adapted the
architecture in a way that leverages
some of the scalability benefits that
the transformer brings to the vision
world. And in particular there is one
architecture we have spent a bunch of
time on which is the diffusion
transformer which relies on that.
So that's one thing. Uh the next thing
is something we have briefly talked
about during lecture I believe lecture
six which is around post-training
approaches and in particular the fact of
injecting negative signals into our
model. So there is uh this um tuning
method called DPO which stands for
direct preference optimization from the
LLM world that was something that was
adapted to the diffusion world. So
that's one and another one that you may
be aware of is GRPO which now is widely
in use in LLMs. That is also something
that has been
something that people have experimented
with in the vision world with flow gpo.
So now you can ask yourself okay text
has given so much to us what can we give
back to text?
Well,
I know this class is not about text, so
I will not go into the details, but one
thing I want to talk about is that in
the text world, we are doing things
mostly in an auto reggressive way. A
little bit like when you and I when we
talk, what we do is we generate one word
at a time and whatever comes out is a
function of whatever came before.
Just to illustrate this. So you have
your LLM which here we say is auto
reggressive. Let's call it an ARM LLM
auto reggressive model. So here we have
let's say a token that says okay we're
starting the sentence. So we say okay a
and then a goes into the model along
with everything that came before and a
teddy and we repeat it again and again.
Teddy bear is reading.
We're generating sentences by
sequentially inputting tokens one at a
time and having the model look at
anything that it has generated before in
order to generate the next token.
Well,
the problem with that
is that if your output sentence or your
output response is long,
then you will take a lot of time
outputting that response
because the number of iterations here is
in O of the number of tokens that you
output.
So in particular um so I'm not sure if
you do a lot of coding on a day-to-day
basis but let's suppose you want to
let's say code a huge thing like a
thousand lines of code
well what that model is doing is really
inputting outputting things one at a
time takes a long time and of course you
want this to be quick.
Well, one idea
is to borrow this idea of diffusion
for text.
So here what you can think of is instead
of doing things one at a time, how about
we do everything at once and we start
from noise and what we do is we
progressively den noiseise in order to
obtain our final
output. Why why wouldn't we do that?
So, by the way, it sounds very
non-natural because I think you're very
used to, you know, saying things in a
sequential way, but
one analogy I want to uh point out here
is
let's suppose you're writing a speech.
So, I'm not sure so first of all, I'm
not sure if you've ever written a
speech, but if you were to write a
speech, you typically don't write things
in a very sequential way. You first
start with a draft. You have some
skeleton of the bullet points you want
to talk about. And then what you do is
you refine, go from coarse to fine
grain.
So what I'm saying is this idea of doing
everything at once, something that
starts from noise up to clean,
although it's not natural,
it is not completely unreasonable
either.
Do you agree with what I'm saying?
Yeah. So let's suppose if we do that
then what we would do is reduce
the complexity from having the number of
iteration being in o of number of output
tokens to being in o of the steps of
diffusion.
So let's see how we want to do that. So
let's assume we take text with random
noise. And by the way, I'm not defining
noise just yet, but just assume that the
text is noised in a way that we will see
later. Let's suppose we have a diffusion
based LLM. So what we're saying is that
we're having this text with less and
less noise
up until
having the cleaned text exactly in the
same way we have done for images. So I
just want to make sure this analogy is
very clear here. We're denoising the
whole input text
in the same way that we're denoising the
whole image all at once.
Well, a natural question is we have seen
that we can think of noise in the image
world as gausian noise.
But for text it's a little bit trickier.
And here's the reason.
In the text world, things are discrete.
So you have words, you have tokens, you
have this, you have that. You're not in
a continuous world.
So in the image world, you would
represent your noise with a continuous
multivaried variable, typically gausian
noise. But how would you do with text?
So one idea you can have is okay let's
let's just throw whatever token we have
that could be one option well the
problem is each token
has a semantic meaning
and so if you just take any token and
you put it as a way to noise your input
they then you may make your input
mean have a meaning that is not a
meaning you may want your input to have.
So for that reason
one thing that the field is starting to
align on which I I believe is the common
most common thing is to have an actual
dedicated token typically a mask token
that that would just represent
a text token that you would not know of.
So a noised text token.
So let's assume you do that.
Then how would we apply what we have
seen so far? Well, we have seen that for
training. So I will spare you all the
mathematical derivations which some of
these papers they go into. We will not
go into that right now. But let's assume
that we want to mimic the training that
we have done for images. How would we do
that?
Well, we would take a clean sentence as
in an unmasked sentence and what we
would do is to corrupt the text
according to a noise level.
And see, so here what does that mean?
That means that we would have let's say
a t% chance, let's suppose t equal 0.5,
a 50% chance of a token in that sentence
being masked. So what we're saying is
let's suppose t equal to.5
we're
masking 50% of the tokens
and then
our training strategy can be to
reconstruct
the tokens that were masked as a
function of whatever was in the input
that was not masked.
So that can be your training objective.
So I know this is not a text class but
for those of you who know about BERT
who's an encoder only architecture
it also has something that is similar as
a pre-training task. The only difference
is here the masking scheme is done with
respect to a noise level that can change
that can vary. So you can have t like a
lot of noise. So almost everything
masked versus a little bit masked.
Whereas for BERT it's always
a certain amount of mass token.
I just want to call that out. So let's
suppose you have that then what you're
doing is you are teaching your model to
fill the blanks.
Well, now how would you go about
actually using such a model at inference
time? So what you would do is same as
what we did for images start with
completely noised inputs. So here a
sequence full of mass token and then
what you would do is
just predict what would be hiding behind
those mass tokens all at once.
But then you want to make sure that you
have
enough buffer for you to make
corrections. So you may want to revise
some tokens that you have predicted.
So the field has several methods to do
that. One of which is just remasking
some tokens in a random way. So some
other methods they remask tokens with
respect to some confidence scores. Like
for instance, if you have a token that
you're unmasking that you're not very
sure of, then you may want to just do
another try. So here you would take some
tokens that let's say you're not sure of
and remask them. And what you would do
is to take
that new sequence and perform the same
operation
meaning
trying to see who is behind that mass
token
and you do that again and again until
obtaining your final output.
So this is a very high level way of how
such a paradigm would work for text.
Well, the good thing is
there is very active research on it and
uh so I was reading one of the papers.
So you can have speeds up to 10x
compared to the traditional auto
reggressive way of doing things and it
is particularly useful for tasks that
requires you to have response as quick
as possible. I know a lot of us are
using uh some form of coding agents to
do our coding work these days and I'm
sure you're you also want your agent to
finish as quickly as possible. Well,
this paradigm would allow you to speed
up that process significantly
and that is the reason why coding is a
very good um use case for that uh for
that paradigm. So on the one hands for
the speed but on the second hand also
because in coding
you naturally have a way to be
interested in filling in the middle kind
of tasks because if you look at your
code base you're rarely always trying to
generate things in a sequential way in
an auto reggressive way. Sometimes you
have a bunch of code and you just want
to generate code let's say in the middle
of two functions.
So for fill in the middle tasks that
paradigm is actually better compared to
auto reggressive tasks. But and we will
not have time to go into details but
training is much more expensive.
Uh particularly because in the
traditional way the way training works
is you input your whole input and then
what you're doing is you're
training your model to predict the next
token and you can parallelize that very
well. And this is unfortunately not
something that you can do as well with
the diffusion scheme.
Then the second thing is there's so many
techniques that now are specific to how
auto reggressive models work that you
would need to adapt.
And
there are also ways to combine the
benefits of the two approaches.
And for instance, block diffusion is an
example of it. So I just wanted to leave
you with this screenshots that just
tells you of the many headlines that you
see around companies that are betting on
this kind of technology. So you have uh
company one such company called
inception that's actually founded by a
professor at Stanford um that's doing
great
and I will just leave you with some uh
suggested readings in case you want and
yeah it's a great question. So the
question is how do you handle the
variable output length? It's a great
question. There are a few ways you can
deal with that. But
in practice you indeed need to set a
given length for your output. And what
you do is you stop whatever is after a
special token called end of sentence
token. Now you can imagine cases where
you're
you're expecting a way bigger output but
you always have shorter output so you're
wasting a lot of computations. So that's
why like the last uh method I mentioned
is something that can be useful. So
block diffusion
is one approach that's being worked on
where you're actually generating text
block by block. So you're saying okay
I'm going to generate let's say text of
size let's say 100 and I'm going to use
diffusion for that and once you generate
such an output if you didn't finish the
output then you will use that as a
condition to perform another round of
diffusion for the second block and so on
and so forth until hitting an end of
sentence token. So you touch a very good
point which is there are some
differences between text and image and
the variable length is one of them.
Yeah. Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So the question is can you apply
this to other discrete things other than
text? I'm sure yes. uh we will not cover
this today but uh the ways people have
derived a tractable mathematical way to
do that in the text world is something
that involves transcribing things for
discrete items so I'm sure that it can
be done um so yeah I would actually
actually highly recommend the first
paper for you to get a sense of how
people go from continuous to this grid
yeah
the Great question. So the question is,
can you not consider text as just being
screenshot of sorry, can you not
consider text as being images of text
and use some kind of OCR mechanism to
process that? So yeah, I think it's
definitely a great approach. There's
actually a paper that was published a
few months ago, deepser that goes into
that. I do think it's promising. I
believe there is some savings with
respect to how many tokens that fills
compared to how many tokens the actual
text would fill in. So yeah, it's
definitely another directions that I
think is promising.
Cool. With that, I'll give it to
Shervin.
Thank you.
So welcome to the last stretch of CME
296. So we're going to see together some
closing thoughts on what lies ahead as
well as some challenges that we see. So
first let's look at today. So when you
look at existing top models, what is the
typical price you have to pay for a
perfect image? So I did the research for
you. I looked at major labs across the
board and it seems that the price per
megapixel is of about 10 cents.
And I think that's going to be a useful
metric to track over time to see the
transition from this being a nice thing
to a commodity.
And of course in reality you wouldn't
use these top models that I listed here
but more of a distilled version. Uh but
still the upper bound gives a good view
of what people would be ready to pay for
for perfect quality.
But then let's look at the kinds of
challenges that could be tackled in the
near term. So one thing that you notice
is that images they're doing well on
them on themselves but there are wins in
other modalities that you are inclined
to include in order to make generation
more powerful. So oneam example that I
have in mind is reasoning with images.
So right now anecdotally if you ask for
a diagram you might get with most models
a projection of what you asked on an
image which is a nice start but it's not
quite the the same level of refinement
as the one you might get in the text
world where you ask a very precise
question and the model goes in searching
for a meaning behind it and then
projecting the exact answer in a concise
So that seems like a good area of uh
research.
And then one topic that I've mentioned
here. So for image editing use cases, it
seems that we're that we're being too
hard on ourselves. We're doing the whole
generation process that is by nature
unconstrained. And it seems we have an
opportunity to use existing tools and
wins in the text world to use agents and
existing
human expertise to make editing happen
in a constraint uh constraints and
tractable way.
And then you have um um other use cases
that could seem attractive to you all.
For example, learning about a class, you
have several streams of information that
come from text. For example, the slides,
the lecture video, and also the audio
the audio track. So, while you can you
can put pieces together one by one.
Today, it seems that there is an
opportunity to bring all modalities to a
consistent and coherent way and generate
synthesis synthesis out of this.
And in the longer run you can see uh the
consequences of all these benefits
across industries that might be lagging
because of some inertia factor. So you
can think of so the field of robotics
which seems to be the next area that
could benefit from a revolution. So in
text we can generate text now like
roughly solved images now we see great
images roughly solved and it seems we
have an opportunity to feed all these
learnings into the ingredients that
could make robotics pick up for example
environments
uh but also medicine and other desk jobs
that might need their own process of
approvals to actually incorporate these
wins.
And maybe one day you won't need to come
to lecture at all and there will be some
model gathering all the pieces for you
in a coherent and pedagogic way. But I
think we might still be far from that
because
the fact of transmitting knowledge still
requires that taste and opinion that
even the text world doesn't have. So I'm
quite curious to see when that will
happen.
on the challenges side. So as we have
seen there are costs and you can use
distillation to alleviate a bit that but
also there is research on the hardware
side where right now hardware is built
on top of matrix multiplies but as you
have seen the building block of these
days models is transformers and which
relies on the concept of attention and
this attention has a very precise
succession of operations that you could
think of simplifying in an analog to
numeric way. So this research paper
could be one such pointer
but also one other concern is the data
quality side because today you see all
these images that are being generated
that are out in the wild. So for the
next generation of models you might
encounter the issue of not finding that
true distribution P data as we had
assumed we had and you have some models
uh some papers that study the phenomenon
of so-called model collapse where
feeding what has been generated
is a way for so looks like an echo
chamber of mistakes that keep growing
and you see that at the end If you
represent embeddings of generations
somewhere, you could clearly cluster the
two.
But how could we deal with that? So
that's the kind of trust point which is
key in our society. You want to be able
to trust images. And now these days with
how similar the true data distribution
and generated images are, it seems like
the border is becoming thin. So two ways
to counter that. There is a norm called
C2PA
that has been gaining traction across
software companies. So you might see
this EI AI info popping in. It's because
images that you create with AI have some
sort of history attached to it that
surfaces it. So that could be one way to
tackle the data collection quality issue
that I mentioned before.
But the thing is if you take a
screenshot of this the meta concept of
metadata disappears. So are we doomed?
Actually no. There are other ways that
we could employ to get around this. One
example is watermarking with example of
synth ID from Google deep mine that
hides behind pixels patterns that reveal
its origin.
So beyond that you also have the topic
of safety which is very important and
creating uh images that are harmful to
others can have societal implications.
So uh there is two parts to fixing this.
One is on the model side where each
company has their own policies to guard
uh such generations but also law is
picking up
and
what can you do from there? So let's say
this class ends uh how can you be
updated? So one uh suggestion is to take
a look at the relevant archive uh
section on computer vision but you might
see that the number of submissions every
day is of hundreds. So this might not be
tractable but on the other hand some
venues do a good job at distilling some
of these works not all but they can give
you an idea of where the field is
heading.
And something else that I want to tell
you is all these papers we saw a bunch
of formulas all over the place and
sometimes you just want to know how they
work. And a great pattern that we see in
the academia um in academia and in the
industry is that there is code release
of what was used to design a given
method. So I highly encourage cloning
the GitHub repo and playing with an AI
assistant coding software on just
guiding you through the flow and you
will learn a ton just by doing that.
And beyond that you have other
resources. So on Twitter you have a
glowing community of people who talk
about these topics. So if your for you
page turns out to be in the clusters of
of these topics, you can get a lot of
interesting recommendations.
And another highlight is other Stanford
courses that talk about vision like 231N
that I recommend.
And there is this study guide that we
shared at the beginning of the class
that we uh aim at keeping up to date
across the years.
But beyond all that, Ashen and I wanted
to say that we're very happy to come
here every Friday and teach this class
and spend time with you. It has been a
pleasure for us and thank you hidden
heroes who came here uh on the evenings
and asked so so many great questions.
You were one of the reasons why the
class was so dynamic and generated
insights that could then be useful to
everyone. Thank you also to those
watching online. Thank you for the great
questions on ed and I hope the class was
of value to you.
And if you are around in the fall, Afin
and I will be teaching a similar class
but in the text world where it will be
our second edition and if you are in for
a new ride then we'd love to see you
again.
And our favorite teddy bear is coming
one last time to wish you a great summer
and all the best. Thank you.
>> [applause]